do we have a question guilt we do yeah
is this live no no this is live
I'm hopeful virus with Bobby colada it's
Stevie we be this is from Brian in Los
Angeles California as a korean-american
it has been difficult for me to
understand where our community stands
culturally I want to have pride in my
community but how can be so when I don't
even know what it means to be
korean-american if you grew up in a
white neighborhood you were called
whitewash if you are more in tune with
Korean culture than the American culture
you were called a fob if you are more in
tune with Latino or black culture you
may as well just fate not face judgment
so basically my question is what do you
think it means to be Korean American or
Asian American where do we stand for me
it's not a complex question because for
me I don't identify with any of those
labels Korean or white or whatnot
because I just hear me out
don't be an Uncle Tom now not being an
Uncle Tom okay what I'm saying is is
that I felt those same things where do I
fit in Korean I'm not that Korean I'm
not the white what I realized is that
I'm my own thing right over all these
character defects you just brought up a
messy these are my views I'm a fucked-up
guy I have a lot of weird things there's
some good traits about me too okay but
that doesn't yeah you know I could just
look at Koreans and go this is what I
like about them I love that they opened
their stores at Christmas do I love it
that's true
they don't there's no we're not gonna
there's no event in life that's gonna
keep them from closing a good restaurant
down the spa I know on Christmas Day
Spas open raves are open karaoke clubs
are open everything's open people are
doing their job because they want to
make money and I love that well I think
this question is more Korean America
like Korean American yeah but I know so
they have that but then you have the
Korean Americans that they hang out with
their white friends and whatnot I'm just
a guy I don't even know what the
question was you stand where you want to
stand I stand what I understand well I
think that's essentially yet it's like
you know you want to
people he his question is whether
whoever you associate yourself with
there's a label to it if you if you hang
out with just Koreans then you're a fob
if you hang out with white people
oh you're to whitewash Twinkie you're a
banana a Twinkie right yeah and if
you're you know then you're urban or
you're this like why can't a
korean-american just stand as is and I
think that they can and that's a that's
a choice that you make and I think that
it's your choice to be affected by those
labels for so long I was called a fob
but I never got offended by it was it
I'm Bob because I came here from the
Philippines and I have an accent
that's the definition of a fob then so
be it I take that you know you don't
have fob tendencies though I have fob
you did not see me earlier I had pride
about we've you've you've changed you've
evolved you're a long time I wasn't just
next there are people I know but better
people out there like I'm not gonna name
names but other people that I know that
even when they came here out of five
they still have fob tendencies I love
fobs I don't know why you're so against
that I I think that you should um you
know um I don't know I just think that
you should be like a relevant person if
you're gonna be if you're gonna be a
show business this is what I'm referring
it to house show business are they
asking about show business
no they're talking about real life
that's my channel question right yeah
anyway can I just say that's last thing
though about it yeah is is that I can't
I can't draw like when I do shows I have
some Asians come out but I'm not like jo
koy or some of these other acts that
fill the rooms with Asians that support
them they don't support me I get a mix
of a lot of different people true and
I'm kind of I thought for a while I was
really bummed out about that like why
can't I you know pull my people in but
then I realize I'm not them I'm not that
you're your own run my own [ __ ] up
thing you know the only one that's
closest to me is David Choe when I met
David Chu I'm like there that's what I
think kind of or that Korean kid that
opens for me Peter sometimes
Peter Peter Kim I look at him I go we're
on the same cloth flamboyant gay
Kurian Kamiya we're just kind of weird
and our own thing and so I'm just
telling this guy don't even think about
it gives a [ __ ] just be your own thing
you don't think you have a
responsibility that you're representing
okay sir people say it people come up to
me and go hey dude like you made me you
know I would what grew up watching you
made me feel proud but there are other
people that have said your disgrace
exactly it's just grace to our people
yeah they're particularly mean for the
most part stations are particularly who
they support you know there was an agent
after who's been in a bunch of movies
they came up to me at the Comedy Store
and he goes he's a little bit of an
accent and he's been in big movies he
goes you you you're a disgrace to our
people yeah and I go what he's gotten
that yeah and he goes just you blew the
pubes out you swear uuuugh me you're
loud okay you see some baby that's what
a Korean American is a Korean American
can do whatever the [ __ ] he wants and
and that's just the end of the story did
it without the pressures of being you
know um you know a straightedge or being
the archetype or academic you can be
that's the perfect you know you set it
right there and then disgusting pull
your pubes out doing whatever the [ __ ]
you want
it's America be Korean American and that
it can be whatever you want it to be but
I was in one time I was in this is what
maybe I was in San Francisco and I was
at the punch line and there was a mold
Japanese man sitting there in the
audience and I item when he came to the
room and in my head I'm like this guy's
gonna hate me
he was me like he was an 8 year old man
but every joke made him almost want to
vomit he was laughing so hard he loved
me that much that's not the response and
after the show he came up to me he goes
he had this weird like whatsapp man
[ __ ] hell and I'm like he could talk
regular you know and I just
urban like you know no yeah but he was
just a guy that was second generation
Japanese guy American he you know didn't
identify with the
Asian comics that were before me like I
mean Henry Cho is very funny but it's a
lot of people like his style you know
whatever but I he identified with me I
mean so it's like you never know
but then the I see I've seen a lot of
older Asian people walk out of my shows
you moose and you see here you go you
know the Ginga yeah like he's gross and
so that's that too you know
just be you a little rage monster like
my brother yeah I always didn't like it
when like I have some
[Music]